an inquiry has revealed a toxic culture
of racism and misogyny in the London far
Brigade this is the independent culture
review Into the London fire brigade
which was ordered by the commissioner
and also by the mayor led by Nazir afsal
Obe uh the uh very famous at QC hearing
experiences of over 2 000 people working
in the Brigade and also at the public
including those who were involved in the
grenfield fire disaster as well talking
about their experiences and it is a
sobering read to say the least some of
the experiences that people talk about
in their time include discrimination and
sexism as well and the London Fire
commissioner Andy Rowe has given a
statement to say that today is a very
sobering day there's no place for
discrimination harassment and bullying
in the Brigade and from today it will be
completely clear to all staff what
behavior isn't acceptable and what the
consequences will be for that behavior
he goes on to say I'm deeply sorry for
the harm that has been caused I'll be
fully accountable for improving our
culture and I fully accept all of the 23
recommendations our chief political
correspondent John Craig joins us and
John what kind of things were uncovered
by this review well this report follows
uh in 250 interviews with former and
current staff and there are some pretty
horrible examples actually he talks
about a female officer whose helmet was
filled with urine and she was also
zipped inside a body bag as part of a
practical joke that officer was
diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder
and the report reveals details of racism
bullying and misogyny it's 88 Pages due
to be published this weekend talks about
a toxic culture in the London fire
brigade now of course there's been all
these sort of allegations about the
Metropolitan Police as well and the new
commissioner as Mark Rowley has
threatened to root all that out well it
looks as though there's a task here for
Andy Rowe he's the Chief Fire officer if
he survives this report that is so let
me tell you some other examples a black
employee finding a noose above his
locker a Muslim firefighter a terrorism
hotline sticker placed near his
belongings and when he returned from
pilgrimage to Saudi Arabia colleagues
asked how his Al-Qaeda training had gone
at some stages assassin Seaman was
smeared on women's uh tunics the report
to describe some of these stories as
stomach turning
at the report is called the independent
cultural review of London fire brigade
it was commissioned following the death
of a trainee at Wembley fire station uh
Jaden Francois Esprit spree who took his
own life in August 2020 was 21 years old
now that inquest heard that the young
man believed he was being bullied at
work because of his ethnicity claims
that he was teased about the Caribbean
food he brought in for lunch he'd made
16 requests to be transferred to another
station so
um these are some of the examples
according to the report in the uh the in
firefighters in England not just in
London
um
uh White officers uh 95 white mixed two
percent Asian or Asian British one
percent black or British one percent
Chinese or other one percent
um now talking it talks actually use the
phrase harrowing examples the author has
said unless a toxic culture that allows
bullying and abuse to be normalized is
tackled I fear that like the young man
um who took his own life others will
take their own lives
um one woman has written in all the
testimony that there is in the report
it's now reached a point with me that I
tell my female friends not to let male
firefighters in the house why because I
know what they do they go through
women's drawers looking for underwear
and sex toys then they will spend hours
bragging about the dildo they found and
will refer to women as [ __ ] and we hear
it all the time and I'm sick of it well
um
this uh obviously this report is bound
to be seized by MPS were critical of the
way the London fire brigade is operating
um and there are bound to be questions
to ministers in the House of Commons on
Monday
um the uh fire brigade comes under I
think I'm writing saying the home office
still or is it leveling up now used to
be the home office
um some real questions for ministers
here and I'm sure that Sadiq Khan when
he responds to this will want to take
some pretty tough action and it may well
be that Andy Rowe the fire brigades
commissioner well if he survives this
he'll be doing well it's extraordinary
isn't it apologies you know for some of
the language that we've heard and some
of the details of this report but you
know as I'm sure you'll appreciate it is
a reflection of what uh Nazir afsel has
found in it I'll bring you the statement
as well by the London Fire commissioner
Andy Ray who said today's a very
sobering day there's no place for
discrimination harassment and bullying
in the the Brigade and from today it
will be completely clear to all staff
what behavior isn't acceptable and what
the consequences will be he apologizes
as well he says I'm deeply sorry for the
harm that's been caused I will be fully
accountable for improving our culture
and I fully accept all of the 23
recommendations so lots of
recommendations in the report John you
were mentioning weren't you the recent
publicity around the Metropolitan Police
it does feel doesn't it that we are
starting to I guess look under the
Bonnet of some of these institutions and
find some quite jaw-dropping examples of
of bullying of misogyny and of racism as
well yes and the numbers some more
numbers for you
um more uh the more of more than four
thousand I think this is the London fire
brigade more than four four and a half
thousand of the five thousand staff are
of uh firefighters that is only four
that's in the London fire brigade only
425 are women just over 500 from ethnic
minorities a tiny proportion in such a
diverse City the report says
um uh that talks about how the work is
uh dangerous and so on
um but um it talks about the report
talks about demonstrable bigotry found
in fire stations
um
um and it goes on to say
um
it seems that the brigade's culture is
pickled in aspic a throwback to the last
century where offensive banter
particularly that characterize that
characterized by extreme sexism was
apparent some watches seem to operate
almost outside the law uh the report
adds there were fights and I nearly had
my legs broken one watch manager says in
the report I've been urinated on
headbutted had cold water poured over me
it was horrendous so
um a mental health Time Bomb it also
talked about as well talks about
increased numbers of Staff leaving the
service since grenfell as well increased
absence related to anxiety stress or
depression
then it goes on to quote a black
firefighter Gareth Davis
experienced a long history of aggression
the nice racism that comes behind a
smile before eventually helping to
create what he turned Progressive space
at his fire station where racist sex is
homophobic language and behavior could
not be tolerated
there's also a mention of the joy George
Floyd death in Minneapolis at the hand
of a police officer and the rise of the
black lives matter movement
um there was due to be a a a a a a a
cultural change gareth's doors actually
I got that name wrong
um he was left feeling unsupported and
isolated
um
and so on yeah
um it does feel it doesn't a bit of a
turning point potentially John thanks so
much for the analysis uh Nazir assel Obe
leading that report into misogyny racism
and bullying at the London fire brigade
he said that he despairs at some of the
findings of the reports and that he
hopes the review would be a turning
point